so yesterday we had the first joint
event of the biden harris ticket with
kamala harris of course
joining joe biden on the ticket the day
before yesterday
i covered this event live on youtube
twitch and facebook and i have to tell
you
the event was remarkable in how
unremarkably normal it was and when
things haven't been normal for a long
time that actually
sort of makes an impression on you and
what i mean by that is joe biden and
kamala harris
were able to stay on topic put together
a simple coherent narrative about why we
should vote for them rather than trump
pence
they spoke in complete sentences
finished thoughts
and it sounds like a very low bar
because it is but that's what's wild
about it a whole bunch of stuff is now
unusual
because of the last three and a half
years of donald trump super interesting
by the way that the viewership for this
event was many times higher than
the viewership for trump's press
briefing which was scheduled at
essentially the same time and
you know there might be some novelty
element biden harris out on the campaign
trail is a new thing and maybe that's
generating interest
but there was this sense of hey this is
kind of normal
and we like it let's look at a few clips
here is joe biden introducing kamala
harris and using this terminology of
whining
which is interesting because when trump
first spoke about harris on tuesday
during the press briefing i said
he's just whining about her and that's
exactly the same language joe biden used
yesterday
you all knew was coming you could have
set your watches to it
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because winding is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history
is anyone surprised donald trump has a
problem with a strong woman or strong
women across the board
then kamala harris speaking and speaking
quite compellingly
going right after trump and in watching
this it is really difficult to imagine
how
mike pence does well against kamala
harris in a debate
trump is also the reason millions of
americans are now
unemployed he inherited the longest
economic expansion in history
from barack obama and joe biden
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because of trump's failures of
leadership our economy has taken one of
the biggest hits
out of all the major industrialized
nations
with an unemployment rate that has
tripled
as of today this is what happens when we
elect a guy
who just isn't up for the job and then
here is kamala harris focusing right in
on coronavirus which i think is smart i
mean when when you look at polling
coronavirus is one of the top issues on
which trump is most upside down where
people think he has failed
and coronavirus is regularly in the top
two issues for what matters most to the
country right now
so i believe this is the right way to
hit donald trump now
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve he said the vice would just
poof go away quote like a miracle
so when other countries opened back up
for business
what did we do we had to shut down
again this virus
has impacted almost every
country but there's a reason
it has hit america worse
than any other advanced nation
it's because of trump's failure
to take it seriously from the start
so here's my thought even if you don't
like kamala harris
in terms of her politics if she is to
your right as she is with me
the energy she's bringing is much needed
and it's a noted
counterpoint to trump pence and in fact
it appears
that that's exactly how polls
show people reacting harris of the four
trump pence biden harris harris is the
only one
polling with net favorability meaning
favorability exceeds people who view her
unfavorably and this is an early sign
that from a strategic standpoint
strategic
this may have been a very good pick it
all remains to be seen
next week we'll have the dnc the next
week after that we will have the rnc
then we will be close to debates and so
it's going to be i mean
this is the election we're weeks away
it's going to be a very busy couple of
months and we're going to be with you
for the entire thing
and uh august 23rd
will be the 15-year anniversary of the
david pakman show we'll be running a
beautiful possibly illegal membership
special
and i encourage you to get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com you'll get
an email on the 23rd telling you how to
take advantage of this
it's just a crazy crazy membership
discount
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video